my guy Fredo bang is back on the show
finally it's been a while man yeah been
a couple of years good to see you bro
they been a little minute huh yeah it
was uh I think the last time you on the
Pod it was like it was definitely two
years ago at least it was I think it was
right maybe like a few months before you
got locked up the last time yeah two
years ago so yeah what's up how's how's
everything man getting ready for the new
project yeah yes I'm sad gu what I'm sad
explain so B
basically uh well there two reasons why
I named it that all the music that's on
this project I made when I was going
through a real rough time in my life
last since I've been out of jail okay
and also it's basically like it's like
an iron and thing it's like basically
showing you okay we can make regular
music and be sad as hell yeah you get
I'm saying also thank you for that
because I feel like I'm tired of just
like
I just feel like hip-hop needs to be a
little more vulnerable yeah be a little
more honest yeah you know what I mean so
when you say cuz cuz cuz it takes a
first of all to name your album that
that's a big that's a that's a brave
thing to do you know what I'm saying
where you going back and forth about
doing it cuz to be like that vulnerable
publicly you know and and you're kind of
seen as like a quote unquote gangster
rapper you know what I'm
saying
oh it was either
that um I forgot what the other name was
was I forgot what the other name was but
it was mainly that one what was uh what
about the last couple of years had you
in a low Place uh it was just going to
jail for nothing and U when I went to
jail you know I was at the top of my
career for real for sure it super slowed
me down I had to refund shows I had to
just basically like I had to just
restart everything on some on some [__]
you know what I'm saying because you
lose your you know it's it's like you
lose that that flow M you know what I'm
saying so just redoing that and then I
had uh labor problems with my main with
my uh independent label so I couldn't
put out no projects I haven't put out a
project in 14 months I was about to say
it's been a minute it's been at least a
year yeah but it's not my fault you feel
me so it's just so cuz for people who
don't know your well I don't know if you
still are you still on Def Jam yeah okay
so you had a uh a label that that deal
was through like your OG label right
from was that from Baton Rouge n okay
but just like an independent label that
yeah so cuz this Rich Homie Quan went
through something similar with uh TIG
okay where they prevented him from
releasing music for years right um so
what was uh what was the disagreement
and how did it end up getting
resolved basically
uh they had a legal situation with a
third another part that kept them uh
back from handling business with me
properly and so it's just was tied up
crisscross and just just deeper getting
worse and worser you know what I'm
saying and we just couldn't settled it
for a while what ended up being the
resolution like what was the The Tipping
Point I don't want to get too too deep
but like I say I don't fault them all
the way because you know stuff happens
[__] happens right people um you know
don't like you said like sometimes it's
just my biggest thing was I felt like um
like they didn't they they helped me get
to where I am I wouldn't be where I'm at
without them but I feel like as the
artist I am the initiatives that I take
as much as work I put in on behalf of
both of us I feel like you know what I'm
saying sometimes you got to swallow the
pill for me you feel me cuz I do the
same for you you feel me so I just feel
like what I was going through I
shouldn't have been going through even
for that long right I should feel like
should immediately got fixed what would
be advice because we've seen recently
similar situations like Megan and uh
1501 I think it was 1501 Carl Crawford
they went through it if you're a young
upand cominging
artist
um sometimes people can come into your
life and and like you said make things
possible for you right when you don't
got nothing so you're just like hey
let's do it but is there any sort of
things people should look out for or
things people should do to kind of
protect themselves from getting into a
situation where that you've that you
kind of like learned from this situation
I'm going say no matter what you do
precautions that you
take how the music industry is set up
and it's not because of just the labels
it's just how [__] be going right it's
so easy for us artist to get [__] out
of our money like that's just plain and
simple it's just easy yeah you know what
I'm saying it's not set in law that this
has to happen that has to happen
sometimes um like with lods I even got
LS that's something I tell everybody get
letter of Direction letter of direction
that make sure what's owed to you get
paid to you and what get Ed to everybody
else go to them so nobody get collecting
somebody money and they got to wait for
them to pay them I got those but my [__]
still messed up to what it couldn't get
put in and and fixed you feel me so for
people who don't know what a letter of
direction is it could
be I'm not like a music lawyer it's just
a signed document saying that it's it's
also how you can like distribute Masters
too like so for example that's that's
old way though huh but let's say you put
an album out right your l or like your
lods would be sent to to Death Jam so
Death Jam knows who to pay before it
hits like yeah someone else's pockets
and you got to depend on that person to
do right by you and see this the thing
like it's Death Jam is the publishing
side BMI cuz there's so many different
sides of the music a lot bro you know
what say got the writer side and you got
the publishing side so that's two right
there you got Death Jam you got the
people who collect the pub they got the
police people who may collect YouTube
separately they got [__] sound
exchang like it's it's a lot bro so who
do you depend on because people I see
people getting taken advantage on by
lawyers too like you also got to kind of
make sure you got you hire the right
lawyer yeah I didn't went through that
too cuz like I didn't hire lawyers that
don't even do [__] and then and they get
a cut for nothing it's like hey you know
I could have probably just Googled this
contract
online I mean it seems like I mean I
most people don't know about the things
we're speaking about most artists yeah
so for you you kind of had to go through
it to be like this ain't going to happen
really as artist learn cuz like I'm
Savage to [__] you feel me and I'm a
type of person where I read [__] three
four times like all my contracts I look
that I go over I wait until I sign them
you know what I'm saying but sometimes
you just don't fully you know what I'm
saying understand until you go through
it you feel me and then you learn and
the next go around it's different you go
around you get it right would you say
you're happy with Dev Jam so far
uh I'm happy in my position yeah uh I
feel like it's always could be better um
I I can't F Death Jam for a lot of
things because they are they are for one
they a legendary label so 100% what
comes with that though is a old horse oh
yeah you feel me so and I'm a very new
horse you feel me so sometimes it's very
hard for those old horses to to break
habit old habits you get what I'm saying
U
also
um you're it's it's a bunch of new
people Steed coming in you feel well
that's what I was going to say since
you've been signed to Def Jam there's
been reg regime changes at the label we
had like three different presidents
right and that I I always feel like if
let's say the president who is there
when you're signed they're going to be
the most excited about you cuz they're
responsible for your signing right or
the anr whoever whoever brought you into
Death Jam right right once they leave
it's up in the air whether or not the
person who replaces them Rosenberg one
who brought me in theide me shout out to
Paul yeah Eminem's manager Goliath
entertainment a legend but it always
like I see it happen all the time where
somebody will get brought into a label
situation and then once their whole
Squad that brought them in leaves and
goes to a different label and then
there's a whole new people and then
they're not as enthusiastic about it or
they don't understand it as well yeah
the good thing with me is uh and shout
out to the president like T I [__] with
tund t there right now great guy and he
a very understanding he for the artist
like % he's he's solid about as solid as
they come yeah and it's hard coming in
trying to fix everything you feel me uh
the thing with me
is
I'm pretty different from a lot of
artists I don't wait on the label to cut
the check to go get the videos done you
just handle it I handle it and I wait to
get it later so and and then you you
you'll file like a reimbursement right
so out the gate I'm productive yeah for
two I'm very but budget savy you know
what I'm saying like I'm I'm not going
[__] to go get a $50,000 video that I
don't need and you can spend three and I
don't feel like it's going to make back
you know what I'm saying and I have
projects that are in the green already
which is nobody has right on major label
systems it's very tough and if if I
could if I can push I pushed out what
three four certifications a bunch of
Chans with Dev jam with three different
PR all this stuff going on what if
everything was consistent right so
everybody knows my worth you know what
I'm saying that's interesting yeah cuz
for people who don't know like if you're
an artist I think a lot of times and and
I'm one of the top streamers over there
you know what I'm saying no shade I want
to shout you out too because I think
you're in a good position at Def Jam
because right
now Def Jam needs a star yeah they don't
have like YG Left Big Sean's like
midcycle like you know uh I know Benny
The Butcher is about to drop his album
but like I feel like Def Jam like you're
the young star on the label now which
can only help you because they need it
like they really like that it's kind of
cold over there you know what I'm saying
in terms of like when you compare them
to like Republic or you compare them to
oscope or you know what I'm saying
capital or RCA but um it's it's funny
you say that your budget Savvy because
you know I always tell artists cuz I
have a recording studio so I always tell
artists like hey I got the big Studio
vocal chain and it's $70 an hour right
but that's fine 70 an hour with an
engineer right but but don't give me the
the label invoice [__] pay for the
studio otherwise they're going to send
you to Paramount or they're going to
send you to like you know one of these
big and it's 250 an hour with an
engineer no I I do pay I do pay
sometimes only time I would I won't is
if I'm locking in for like 2 three weeks
and I got FK cuz sometimes I that's what
I'm saying people people you know
there's people who come to LA they'll
stay in the studio for like a week
straight and I'm like bro you know how
much that week cost you and and you're
over here ordering [__] Boston
NOA cuz it when when it come to me
bringing four five producers in flights
so it's a lot more money involved so
just so they know I'm not on some trying
to eat at my budget type cuz some some
weird people do that and I don't know
why they do that cuz you just taking
money that you got to pay back well
those artists they live off advances
they don't that's there's a lot of
artists I know who they're like hey man
they give you get that advance and you
don't ever think you're going to see
another red scent off that album yeah so
it's like I got to get the next album
then turn it in so I get my you know
half a million or whatever it is that's
that's dope you got you got a bunch of
music in the green cuz that's not a
comment practice with a lot of young
artists cuz they [__] that budget off
yeah I mean and it's hard the the cut is
very hard to get in the green like your
music got have to do good and your
budget has to be low to get in the green
fast what uh was something that you were
able to like do to kind of get out of
the funk you were in um because you had
so much momentum and you still I mean
look it's not like you don't have
momentum like yeah it's just but you you
have to was on the radio everywhere I be
wanting more out myself no but I'm
saying like how were you able to pull
yourself out of that and just kind of
like did it kind of like make you
hungrier like you get out of jail are
you like super [__] laser focused or
you just a little discouraged at first
so when I got out of jail I had to go
through a process of the rest of my
papers mhm so at first they wouldn't let
me go back home to my house I about had
to get a new house so it was just in
Florida or in Baton in Florida it wasn't
letting me go back at first so I it just
there so many things I had to go through
so my mind wasn't all the way focused
and like I said I forgot my rhythm so
now I'm trying to fix I'm taking so long
to try to fix the labor issues I'm not
focused on getting my music out by any
means necessary you know what I'm saying
and so it's just I I wasn't focused and
right now and when when you do get out
focus you got to find that confidence
again because you feel me like that's
when the people don't realize it's
almost like when you're a basketball
player and that shots not going in you
just got to shoot yourself out of the
[__] right right and so then that's when
the comments start getting to you though
that's when it start [__] with you
you know what I'm saying so do you find
yourself reading comments yeah I read I
read everything I watch I watch
everything you got to stop no the reason
why I don't is because I want that good
or bad you know what it is though you
got here doing you unapologetically yeah
what's going to happen is you you you
you spend too much time reading the
comments even if you don't think it's
affecting you subconsciously yeah it's
affecting you subconsciously you'll
think of that one bro the you got to
understand the type of human beings that
leave comments on YouTube videos and
like these posts [__] neck hurt
my bad like imagine S Flex he said man
this [__] heavy my neck
hurt um no but imagine like I always
tell this to people like you know cuz
like I have a YouTube channel and
sometimes I'll get stuck reading the
comments and I be like damn someone left
a paragraph under this video they took
three five minutes out of their day yeah
to to comment on a stranger piece of
content something negative like imagine
like how [__] up in your days got to
be your life got to be sometimes it'll
be sometimes it could be like it'll be a
troll but it'll be funny to me and
sometimes it brighten up a day sometimes
make me mad you know what I'm saying it
just yeah like if I if something ever
comes across my Twitter timeline that's
negative I just retweet it yeah cuz I
don't give a [__] yeah I just like [__]